تزامنا مع اجلاء البعثات الاجنبيه برا
وجوا تجدد اطلاق الرصاص في مناطق بالخرطوم
بحري بعد معارك نهاريه قرب المطار وفي
محيط القصر الجمهوري اشتباكات بام درمان
غربي العاصمه تقارير عن فرار عدد من نزلاء
سجن كوبر والشرطه تقول انه تم التحفظ على
رموز النظام السابق في مكان امن
بالتداعيات الانسانيه للمواجهات في
السودان منظمه الصحه العالميه تكشف عما
وصفتها بهجمات مميته على مؤسسات صحيه
وتقول ان ربع الضحايا كان يمكن انقاذهم لو
تمكن المسعفون من الوصول الى مناطق
المعارك ومخاوف من ازمه نزوح ولجوء واسعه
النطاق
اذا هيمنه عمليات الاجلاء على المشهد
السوداني مع تلاحقي الترتيبات لنقل
الرعايه الاجانب وكذلك البعثات
الدبلوماسيه لكن قبل رصدي ابعاد ذلك
وتداعيته نبدا من التطورات الميدانيه حيث
افاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع دوي انفجار قوي
في جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم مساء اليوم وذلك
بعد تجدد اطلاق نار ليلي في الخرطوم بحري
كما افاد مراسل الجزيره بانقطاع التيار
الكهربائي ونقص مياه الشرب في العديد من
احياء العاصمه وقال مراسل الجزيره جنوب
الخرطوم ان عددا من السودانيين نزحوا من
العاصمه الى ولايات اكثر امنا مثل الجزيره
وود مدني اعتزامن ذلك مع اخر يوم في ايام
في ايام هدنه عيد الفطر الثلاثه التي اعلن
الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع الالتزام بها
هذا وكاله الخرطوم قد شهدت صباح اليوم
اشتباكات متقطعه في محيط القصر الرئاسي
وسط العاصمه واخرى في احياء مبدا في ام
درمان غربا الخرطوم وقال مراسل الجزيره ان
العاصمه عاشت منتصف نهار اليوم على وقع
هدوء حذر رافقه نشاط لحركه اجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه الاجنبيه برا وجوا انطلق فجر
اليوم الاحد
على صعيد متصل قالت قوه الدعم السريع ان
الجيش السوداني خرق الهدنه المعلنه وقصف
قوه الدعم السريع في منطقه كفوري في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري بالطائرات وقالت هذه القوات
في بيان ان القصف طال منازل مواطنين ما
ادى الى مقتل واصابه العشرات وفق ما جاء
في البيان ودانت قوه الدعم السريع هذا
القصف الذي قالت انه يتنافى مع الالتزام
المعلن بالهدنه ومدتها
72 ساعه
في المقابل نفى الجيش السوداني ما اعلنته
قوه الدعم السريع عن سيطرتها على موقع
مدينه جياد الصناعيه في الخرطوم وقال انه
لا وجود حاليا لمن وصفهم بالمتمردين في
المدينه الصناعيه
تداولت حسابات سودانيه محليه عبر منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي تسجيلا مصورا قالت انه
يظهر قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حميطي في محيط القصر الجمهوري بتاريخ غير
محدد
ويظهر المقطع الذي بث اليوم يظهر رتلا
عسكريا للدعم السريع ويظهر حميد تجالسا في
احدى مركبات الرتل وبالبحث عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه والتاكد من المباني الوارده في
الصور تبين ان الفيديو التقط بجوار مقر
ديوان الحكم الاتحادي القريب من القصر
الجمهوري
افاد مصدر بالشرطه السودانيه للجزيره انه
تم التحفظ على رموز النظام السابق في مكان
امن بعد ترحيلهم من سجن كوبر الذي شهد
حاله هروب جماعي للنزلاء هذا اليوم هذا
وكان مصدر بوزاره الداخليه السودانيه قال
للجزيره ان عدد النزلاء الفارين يقدر
بالمئات بينهم سجناء محكوم عليهم بالاعدام
مشيرا الى ان السجناء السياسيين لم يكونوا
ضمن المجموعه التي هربت في المقابل اتهمت
قوات الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني باخلاء
السجن بالقوه الجبريه وفق تعبيرها
معنا من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره هيثم اويت
هيثم اخر المستجدات لديك
عبد القادر اخر المستجدات نبدا من بيان
حديث للجيش اصدره قبل قليل في القياده
العامه قال بان عمليات الاجلاء التي تمت
اليوم بمساعده الجيش تم اجلاء بعثات
الدبلوماسيه كل من البعثه القطريه وبعثت
الاردن عبر طريق البري الى ميناء الى
منطقه بورسودان ومنها من مطار بورسودان
استخدم الطائرات الى الولايات النهائيه
لهما ايضا قال بان هناك بعثات دبلوماسيه
اخرى تم اجلائها عن طريق مطار وادي سيدنا
العسكري في منطقه كرري وهي بعثات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وفرنسا وبريطانيا
والمانيا وقال الجيش بان بقيه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه التي قدمت طلباتها للاجلال
سيتم العمل على اجلائها ائمه عن طريق البر
او عن طريق المطار الحربي للجيش هذا جانب
ايضا الجانب الاخر من البيان اتهم فيه
قوات الدعم بانها قامت بالتعدي على بعض
البعثات الدبلوماسيه وانها وصلت قصفها
ومحاوله استيلائها على بعض المواقع
الاستراتيجيه في العاصمه الخرطوم وايضا
محاوله استلائها على ام صفات الجيلي في
شمال الخرطوم وكذلك
تخريبها الاداره الهاتف السوداني وادى ذلك
الى انقطاع الانترنت هذا من جانب بيان
الجيش ايضا من جانب اخر الدعم السريع كان
له ايضا بيان اتهم فيه الجيش بقصف مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريع في بحري وقام يعني
قصفها اثناء ايضا محاولتها لتامين بعثات
دبلوماسيه هذا ما قاله بيان الدعم السريع
ميدانيا اليوم كان يوم يعني متقلب فبدا
هادئا ثم كان هناك اشتباكات متقطعه ازدادت
في فترات معينه وعاد الهدوء ليسيطر في
ساعات طويله منذ الظهر اليوم حتى المساء
ما عدا بعض الاص انفجارات التي كانت في
مساء اليوم لكن عموما هذه الاجواء وهذه
التوترات التي حدثت منذ اليوم الاول وحتى
اليوم اليوم التاسع افرزت الكثير من
المشكلات السالبه وكانت هناك ايضا بعض
الفوضى التي حدثت مثل هروب السجناء من سجن
كوبر وسجن الهدى وايضا بعض هؤلاء المساجين
يعني منهم من هو متهم بجرائم القتل العمد
وايضا كانت هناك انتشرت ببعض العصابات
التي تنشط في مجال السرقه وايضا هناك ما
زالت جثث ملقاه على بعض الطرقات وانقطاع
الكهرباء عن احياء عديده من الخرطوم خاصه
احياء البحري وشرق النيل كل هذه يعني من
انعكاسات هذا الصراع الدائري وهناك مخاوف
من تجدد هذا الصراع بعد انتهاء المهله
التي انتهت اليوم ولا حديث الان عن مهله
او هدنه جديده الهدنه انتهت اليوم ولكن
حتى الان لم تتفق الاطراف ولم تتجه في
البحث عن الهدنه جديده ما يثير القلق
والخوف وسط المواطنين هنا في السودان طيب
اذا فيما يتعلق بالوضع حتى الان هيثم هناك
هدوء تام في العاصمه الخرطوم
نعم هناك هدوء تامه في هذا المسام عدا
اصوات متقطعه كان هناك حوالي سمعنا مرتين
او ثلاث مرات اصوات الانفجارات ولكن ما
عدا ذلك هناك هدوء بشكل كبير يسيطر على
مجمل الحياه في الخرطوم بعد ان شهدت
الايام الماضيه اشتباكات عنيفه وكانت يعني
سببت هلع كبير في او نفوس المواطنين وسببت
ايضا يعني انعكاسات سالبه وفي الجانب
الانساني والجانب الصحي وكان لها اثر بالغ
في حياه الناس والان هذا الهدوء يبعث
الامل ربما اذا كان هناك اتجاه لتجديد هذه
الهدنه او ربما يتجه الطرفان الى خفض
واخفي هذا التصعيد
شكرا لك هيثم اويت كنت معنا من الخرطوم
معنا هنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني اهلا بك
ضياء ضياء
كيف تتابع الشان في هذا اليوم في ظل
التطورات خاصه ما تعلق منها بالتطورات
الميدانيه حتى الان
لتطورات ميدانيه اساسيه ولكن الامر
الاساسي هو واجلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه
وممارسه الدعم السريع
لسيناريو الفوضى وهو اطلاق صراحه المهاجمه
السجون ومهاجمه بعض المستشفيات تحت ان هذه
المعطيات واضح انه الدعم السريع الاتهام
الدعم السريع للجيش بانه هو من اتهامات
متبادله ولكن المنطق والغراين يقول بان
الجيش لن يستفيد باطلاق الصراحه السجناء
واطلاق المرضى النفسانيين من المستشفيات
وغيره وحرق
البنوك مثل ما حدث في بنك الجزيره
القرائن والشواهد تقول ان
الجهه الان الموجوده على الارض فعليا في
هذه المناطق وهي الدعم السريع طيب انتهاء
الهدنه هل يعني شيء خاصه انها هدنه لم يتم
الالتزام بها هي هدنه اعلاميه فقط
ولكن في الواقع ليس هنالك هدنه قد تتراجع
المواجهات لاسباب ميدانيه فقط ولكن لا
تتراجع النتيجه للقرار السياسي او القرار
من القيادات خاصه وان الدعم السريع الى حد
كبير جدا فقد المساله التحكم
واداره القوات على الارض لان شبكه
الاتصالات ضربت مركز التحكم
فيواجه مشاكل كبيره جدا فمعظم هذه
المجموعات العسكريه تتعامل وفقا المعطيات
بفرض عليها الواقعه المباشر في في مناطقها
وفي اماكن اكثر من كوننا ان هنالك قرارات
تصدر اليها فتمتسل اعتقد قبل قليل ايضا
كان معنا مراسل جزيره هيثم وتكلم عن
البيان الاخير للجيش مشيرا فيه الى دور
الجيش في مساله اجلاب البعثات الدبلوماسيه
حتى هذه المساله في اليومين الماضيين ايضا
كانت محل ايضا كل طرف يقول بانه ساهم بشكل
او باخر في الوصول الى هذه النتائج وتحسين
الصوره المجتمع الدولي كله طرف يريد ان ان
يقدم نفسه بانه حرز على الجوانب الانسانيه
وحرزه على البئسات لان ذلك سيساعده
مستقبلا اذا وصل الى السلطه في العلاقه
بالمجتمع الدولي لكن من الواضح ان الدعم
السريع تضرر من هذا الامر حينما اعلم بانه
نصق مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
اجلاء بعثتها وصدر بيان من الخارجيه
الامريكيه بانه لم يكن هنالك اي تنسيق مع
الدعم السريع فبالتالي اعتقد ان هذه
النقطه هنا الصراع يدور في الداخل ولكن
العيون تنظر الى الخارج العيون الجيش
والدعم السريع كلاهما ينظر الى الخارج
باعتبار ان هنالك تحديدات باصدار عقوبات
كل طرف يريد ان يبرر نفسه ويدين الاخر
ويقول بانه يتعاون
ويراعي الجوانب الانسانيه ولكن واضح انها
تداعيات الميدان هي التي تفرض ظرفها وهي
الميدان اشرت الى ما اسميتها بالهدنه
الاعلاميه انتهت البعثات الدبلوماس
الدبلوماسيه غادرت الخرطوم هناك تخوف ما
بعد مغادره هذه البعثات للخرطوم وما قد
يحدث من انزلاقات خطيره فيما يتعلق بتوسع
دائره الاشتباك يبدو ان هذه القرارات
الاخلاء مرتبطه لتقدير موقف معظم الدول
وخاصه
تستمر لفتره اطول وربما تصبح اكثر شراسه
وبالتالي يصعب عليها الاحساس ستهدد في في
ممتلكاته في حياه
الدبلوماسيه فبالتالي هي قرات الموقف بان
هذا الامر لن يحسم قريبا او ربما يصبح
اكثر شراسه وضراوه فلذلك قررت الاجلاء طيب
الدولي مع مجلس السودان حتى العقوبات هذه
العقوبات كوسيله ليست مبديه في هذا الوقت
تداعيات الميدان هي التي تفرض الامر
الواقع فلا اعتقد ان هنالك اذان تستمع
الان لهذه النصائح او هذه التهديدات
الاذان فقط تستمع لاصوات الرصاص وللبنادق
وتنظر الى مواقع المواقع لان هذه الحرب
اذا انتهت في هذا الوقت لها مترتبات
سياسيه واذا انتهت في فتره قادمه لها
مترتبات قد تكون اخرى فبالتالي الصوت
الميدانيه هي المتحكمه الاكبر تاتي
الاعتبارات الاخرى لتجميل الصوره كما كنت
قبل قليل ولكنها لا تمثل عامل مركزي وعامل
حاسم فيما يتعلق باستمرار الحرب او
التهدئه او او توقف تماما عندما سالتك في
بدايه حوارنا سيدي ضياء عن التطورات
الميدانيه قلت ليس هناك تطورات بالمعنى
الدراماتيكا او الذي يؤدي الى انتقال
حقيقي نحن الان تجاوزنا مده اسبوع ومداله
ما زال المشهد كما هو في مقابل دعايه من
الطرفين تقدمنا في هذا المكان استولينا
على هذا المكان وحتى صور كما شاهدنا قبل
قليل لسيد حميتي من امام احد المقرات
الجمهوريه انا موجود في الميدان ما الذي
يعنيه حتى الان اسبوع وما زالت الصوره كما
هي ميدانيا وحتى دعائيا
الخاص بين الطرفين كان خاطئ الدعم السريع
كان بامكاني كان ينظر بانه يستطيع ان يوجه
ضربات قاضي وسريعه بحركته السريعه وان
يسيطر على الاوضاع ويلقي القبضه القبض على
على البرهان ووضع هذه غايات واهداف
بالنسبه له هو فشل في ذلك تماما وكان
الجيش ينظر بانه باستطاعته ان ينتهي من
هذه ان ينهي هذه الحاله في ساعات او في
ايام ولكن تداعيات الوضع افرضت واقع جديد
واصبح الامر ليس ليس هنالك طرف يتحكم في
النهايات هنالك معركه اساسيه اعتقد انها
ستغير الاحداث هي السيطره على وسط الخرطوم
سنتر الخرطوم هذه المنطقه المنطقه يعني في
مشاركات ثنائيه بين الطرفين وفي نزاعات
وفي اماكن حساسه الجيش يراعي لجوانب
الانسان وسط الخرطوم بما فيها القصر
القياده
والقياده والمطار والخرطوم اثنين وشرق
المطار هذه منطقه ملتهبه من يسيطر على هذه
المنطقه بشكل نهائي ويكاد يكون قطع اكثر
من 50% في انهاء في في تحسين اوضاعه بشكل
كبير ولكن اذا ظلت الامر على يعني الامر
استمر على ما هو عليه لا اعتقد ان ان
هذه الحرب ستضع وزاره قريبا طيب ايضا الان
التساؤل بعد مرور كل هذه الايام عن
الاحزاب
السياسيه في السودان عن الفاعلين
السياسيين في السودان اذا كانت الدول
الكبرى على حجمها فاشله حتى في تثبيت هدنه
هناك تحرك هناك بيانات تصدر من الاحزاب
هناك حديث عن مبادرات هل هي صيحات في واد
في ظل لغه الرصاص السائده في ظل هذا الوضع
ولا اعتقد ان هنالك من يستمع اليها
السياسيه قوه قاصره على فهم استيعاب
المشهد وهي التي دفعت بالاوضاع نحو هذا
ساهمت لا اقول انها وحدها ولكن ساهمت في
التسريع عبر الاتفاق الايطالي الذي حاول
ان يعطي الدعم السريع وضعي امتياز موازي
للجيش في الفتره الانتقاليه فبالتالي هو
اشعل هذه التناقلات التناقضات اصلا موجوده
الثنائيه ما كان لهذه الثنائيه ان تستمر
ولكن ما اجعل هذه التناقضات وما اودى بهذه
الثنائيه هو الاصرار على تطبيق الاتفاق
الايطالي الذي يفصل الدعم السريع من قياده
الجيش ليضعها تحت قياده مدنيه وذلك يسمح
لها بالتسليح ويسمح لها بان تزداد في
القوه وتزداد في دون ان يكون هناك رقابه
من قبل الجيش والجيش كمؤسسه لديه
لديه شعور بجرح كبرياء من وجود الدعم
السريع وتمدد الدعم السريع ومن سيطره
الدعم السريع على بعض الانشطه الاقتصاديه
وغير ذلك فهنالك دافع دافع مؤسسي فوق
للاجنده الاخرى المتعلقه بالصراع على
السلطه او الصراع المتداخله
ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب والمحلل هنا في
الاستوديو لاستقبل ضيفي من الخرطوم سيد
جميل الفاضل الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
الجميل الان او في هذه الليله ستنتهي هذه
الهدنه ماذا بعد انتهاء هذه الهدنه التي
اصلا لم يتم الالتزام بها
نعم بطبيعه الحال
كعاده الايام السابقه
واعلان الهدنه لاربع مرات لهذه المره
الخامسه تقريبا الصوره هي ذات الصوره وجرث
الامور على ذات الوتيره وبذاعه الشكل عدم
التزام باي هدنه تعلن عدم التعامل مع هذه
الاعلانات بشكل جاد لا توجد صدريه في
الالتزام من قبل كلا الطرفين المتقاتلين
بايقاف اطلاق النار هذا هو هذا هو المشهد
والذي ربما يتكرر لان كل هدنه اعلنت تمت
بمبادره من جهه خارجيه
وتمت باتصالات جرت مع الجنرالين
من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من غيرها من
الجهات التي بادرت بمحاوله ايقاف اطلاق
النار المؤقت انا في
[موسيقى]
انا حقيقه فيما يتعلق بالحرب انا اتعلق
اتصور ان المسؤوليه هي مسؤوليه الجنرلين
معا لا اتصور ان هناك طرف لا يستطيع ان
يبرئ نفسه من مقببته ومسؤوليه ما حدث على
الشعب السوداني
الدخول في هذه الحرب اتى بتصورات فطيره من
كلا الجانبين
كليهما ربما يتصور بانها نزهه
خاطفه يمكن ان تتم في سعاد ويحسم الامر
لصالحه هذه القضيه الان من الواضح تماما
انها ستستمر الى مدى اطول
وستاخذ عده اشكال وتماثورات
ويمكن ان تتدحرج كره اللهب وتذهب الى
مناطق واسعه من السودان اعتقد انه هذه
الصوره يتحمل وزرها الذين بادروا
واستسهلوا امر الحرب واعتبروا ان خلافاتهم
او الجهه التي ايضا انا اعتقد ان هناك طرف
وايادي قاسمه تحرك هذه الافعال كلها من
وراء الستار وتدفع كل الطرفين الى ان
يسقطها في هذا المستنقع وجر البلاد برمتها
الى هذه الاوضاع انا يعني اعتقد ان هناك
جمله الحديث بلسان الطرفين
تتحمل الحديث بلسان الطرفين الا يجرن في
المستقبل عندما يسال السودانيين من يتحمل
مسؤوليه ما يجري الان ستضيع الاجابه
بالحديث على ان الطرفين
نعم انا اعتقد ان هناك طرف اذكى من
الطرفين
جر اقدامهم الى مسرح العمليات والحرب
والمواجهات وهذا يخدم اجنده النظام القديم
هذا في تقديري واتصور ان النظام القديم قد
ابلح الان في الايقاع بالبلاد كلها في
اتون هذه الحرب الان الماساه الانسانيه
تتصاعد
واتصور ان هذه الحرب هي جزء من كان يعني
قد تاجرت بدرجه كبيره كان ينبغي ان تكون
في الحادي عشر من ابريل تم الذهاب بها الى
محاوله اخرى بفضل اعتصامه للقياده في
الثالث من يونيو في العام 2019 عندما اتى
انقلاب الخامسه والعشرين من اكتوبر كلها
محاولات تدور في كيف يمكن ان يستعيد
النظام القديم وجوده ويحكم قبضته على
السلطه ولذلك الان هذا تجلي ايضا من
تجليات هذا الصراع المستمر ادخال البلاد
كلها في المعارك وفي المواجهات وفي
الاشتباكات المستمره واعتقد ان الفاتوره
الباهظه التي سيدفعها الشعب السوداني هي
جزء من
تدابير وضعت لكي يصبح الانسان لا يستطيع
ان يرى اين الصح واين الخطا الى اين يجب
ان يقف اين يمكن ان يتوضع هل وقف هو في
الجانب الخطا من التاريخ ام في الجانب
الصحيح من التاريخ هناك اسئله كثيره يتم
الحديث باسم الوطنيه والوطن ترتفع
الشعارات التي تنادي
الطرف لانه يعبر عن الوطن والقوميه
وان تنقع
وان تنعى ان تنعم
انه يمثل الوقت قد ادركنا
من الخرطوم الجميله الفاضله الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي
حصلت الجزيره على صور تظهر انتشارا لقوات
الدعم السريع على امتداد شارع عبيد ختم
بالخرطوم وقال قاده ميدانيون من الدعم
السريع ان قواتهم تسيطر على مناطق واحياء
الكويت والطائف والرياض وبري والمعموره
والجريف والمنشيه في جنوب شرق العاصمه من
شارع افريقيا وحتى كوبري بري كما حصلت
الجزيره على صور لجانب من مطار الخرطوم
التقطت من الناحيه الشرقيه تظهر عددا من
الطائرات وقوات الدعم السريع بمحاذاه مبنى
هيئه الطيران المدني كما حصلت الجزيره على
صور لسجناء قال قائد ميداني من الدعم
السريع انهم فروا من سجن سوبر جنوب
الخرطوم وانه سيتم التحفظ عليهم لحين
استقرار الوضع وتسليمهم للسلطات المعنيه
دافيا ضلوع الدعم السريع في عمليه فراره م
من السجن
هذا وكان الجيش السوداني اكد في تصريحات
سابقه ان المواجهات حول المطار ما زالت
مستمره ونفت تمكن قوات الدعم من السيطره
عليه بشكل تام وكان الجيش قد اعلن في وقت
سابق انتشار قواته على امتداد شارع المطار
لفرض هيبه الدوله وملاحقه قوات الدعم في
المنطقه حسب تعبيره
من امام الساحه الخضراء من جانبه نشر
الجيش صورا قال انها للاستسلام قوات الدعم
السريع والسيطره على موقع لها في الفشقه
الصغرى جنوب شرق السودان
[موسيقى]
مكان الجيش والسوداني قد نشر في وقت سابق
صورا قال انها لجوله تفقديه قام بها نائب
رئيس هيئه الاركان الفريق الركن عباس
الداروطي للجنود في القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه
وبرج القوات البحريه
ايضا نشر الجيش السوداني مقطعا مصورا يظهر
مخاطبه احد ضباط الجيش اسرى قال انهم من
قوات الدعم السريع سلموا انفسهم لقوات
الشرطه
معنى من الخرطوم عزمي عبد الرازق الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد عزمي ايضا
نحن دخلنا في اي مرحله الان مع خروج هذه
البعثات الدبلوماسيه الاجنبيه وتخوفات ان
تقول الامور انسانيا لما هو اسوا
وطبعا بعد تم ارجاع البعثات الدبلوماسيه
عبر محورين محور البحر الاحمر ودي البعثات
العربيه القطريه والاردنيه
والبعثات الاوروبيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بريطانيا وفرنسا تم ايداع عبر
قاعده وادي سيدنا عبر طيران عسكري يعني
بحمايه من
السلاح الطيران الغربي تقريبا من
الناتو
ويبدو بانه البعثات الدبلوماسيه تحديدا
الطاقم السفالي تم ايجابي بشكل كامل ولكن
عدد كبير جدا برضه من رعايه تلك الدول ما
زالوا موجودين في السودان
والظروف والتعقيدات العسكريه الان لا تسمح
لها كل الاطراف في نفس الوقت يعني يتجدد
اطلاق النار فتحديدا في محيط القصر
الرئاسي باتجاه منطقه منطقه بحري لانه
منطقه بحري فيها تواجد الدعم السريع
بطبيعه الاسلحه الموجوده في تلك المنطقه
لانه اصلا القوات المسلحه يعني عندها
قواعد هي سلاح النقل وسلاح الاشاره ودي
وحدات تقريبا هي ما وحدات مقاتله وبالتالي
يعني
يتمكن القوات الدعم السريع من الانتشار في
تلك المنطقه وذلك كثير جدا من المعارك في
تلك المنطقه لكن المنطقه اتوسط سيد عزمي
وركز معك على مساله
التخوفات الان عن مساله التخوفات سيد عزمي
تسمعوني
اسالك عن التخوفات الان بنعلم لما ذكرته
فيما يتعلق بخروج البعثات الدبلوماسيه
ايضا اليوم تم قطع شبكه الانترنت وبالتالي
هناك تخوفات هنا وهناك انه ربما قد تشهد
العاصمه وضع المتدهورا ورغابه دوليه
في غياب الرقابه الدوليه المتوقع انه تكون
هنالك حالات اشتباك كبيره جدا في الساعات
المقبله خصوصا بانه اي طرف الان حريص عليه
ان يحقق على الاقل نتائج على الارض ليمارس
بها نوع من الضغوط ونوع من النمو موجود في
ارض المعركه
ويتمتع بالافضليه ولكن
الاشكاليه والمزعل الماء موجوده في
الحسابات هو المواطن المواطن الان بيدفع
فاتوره كبيره جدا وتكلفه الفاتوره عاليه
لصراع الاطراف خصوصا الاوضاع الانسانيه
واوضاع
الاوضاع السيئه على مستوى التغذيه الغذاء
على مستوى المرافق الصحيه الموظفين معروف
عندما بدا القتال لم يصرفوا رواتبهم
وهذا يعني تسبب في ضائقه معيشيه كبيره جدا
يعني قبل اجازه العيد ما صرف رواتبهم كل
الاموال التي بحوزتهم نفذت تمام مع ارتفاع
اسعار المواد الغذائيه والمواد
الاستهلاكيه الخوف والسينار والاخطر هو
اتساع رقعه الفوضى ومحاولات الناقصه بانه
في عدد كبير جدا من المساجين طلعوا من
السجون وفي يوم ناسا ومحتاديه اجرام لان
ممكن يعني يثير حاله من الهلع وسط المجتمع
الغياب الظاهر جدا للشرطه السودانيه وان
الاطراف العامه بتفتح مسارات لتحرك
توزيع حصص الدقيق وكذلك يعني تعطل خدمات
الكهرباء والمياه المزاد هي فاقمه الاوضاع
سوءا ومن المتوقع انه ما لم تكون هنالك
تنازلات من الطرفين بحيث انه يسمح
لفرق الانقاص فرق الدعم فرق اصلاح محطات
المياه ومحطات الكهرباء انه من وكذلك
حمايه المتاجر والاسواق بحيث انها تتمكن
انها تفتح وكذلك توزيع حصه دقيق هذا ما لم
تكون هنالك على الاقل هود تضمن سلامه هذه
الاطراف للمتوقع انه يدخلوا المواطنين لما
يدخل المواطنين
هنالك حالات احتجاج وشغب ما في زول بيقدر
يوقفون المتوقع انه الخسائر تكون كبيره
جدا الان في طرفين بيتقاتلوا الطرف الثالث
هو اللي بيدفع الفاتوره بتاعت هذا القتال
اذا اضطر في النهايه نزل الشارع وحصلت
حالات فوضى هنا ممكن تكون هنالك تدخلات
دوليه ممكن يستدعي البنده السابع وبالتالي
من المهم جدا مراعاه الاوضاع الانسانيه في
هذه الحرب يعني الان نحن دخلنا على اليوم
العاشر وحتى الان القتال لم يتوقف كله طرف
عايز يكون حديث عليه انه يحقق افضليه ولكن
عموما واضح تمام بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تتمتع بافضليه من خلال الان
يعني تحولت مين امتصاص الصدمه الاولى بحيث
انه كان هنالك هجوم على القياده والطلبه
الواضح للدعم السريع في اول
الوقت قياده من الخرطي الدوله تماما
السياسي من الخرطوم شكرا
احدث هذا التفارق او الفرق في الوقت بين
الاجابه وبين السؤال شكرا تحاول دول كثيره
الاستفاده من الهدوء النسبي الذي يشهده
السودان لاجلاء رعايا وتستهدف اغلب عمليات
الاجلاء في الوقت الحالي موظفي السفارات
وذويهم في الاثناء قال نطق باسم الجيش
السوداني ان عمليه الاجلاء التي تم
تنسيقها بواسطه الجيش عن طريق البرد هي
لبعثتي قطر والاردن وان البعثات التي تم
اجلائها جوا هي بعثاه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبريطانيا والمانيا وفرنسا هذا
التقرير يقربنا من هذه العمليات والصعوبات
التي تواجهها
سباق مع الوقت لاجلاء من يمكن اجلائهم من
السودان الولايات المتحده اعلنت انها اجلت
اقل من موظف سفارتها في الخرطوم وذويهم
شارك في العمليه مئه من جنود القوات
الخاصه تحركوا من القاعده الامريكيه
بجيبوتي ونقل من تم اجلؤهم الى مكان غير
معروف باثيوبيا اما فرنسا فقد شهدت عمليه
اجلاء موظفي سفارتها اطلاق نار جرح فيه
شخص واحد على الاقل وتبادل الجيش والدعم
السريع الاتهامات بشان المسؤول عن الحادث
وتتكتم السلطات الفرنسيه عن عمليه الاجلاء
التي تنطلق من قاعدتها بجيبوتي يسود
الكتمان ايضا في بريطانيا بشان عمليه
الاجلاء نقلت وسائل اعلام بريطانيه عن
مصدر في الخارجيه ان عمليه اجلاء جرت من
موقع جوي خارج الخرطوم دون تفاصيل لم
يحالف نفس النجاح المانيا في البدايه تعرض
الثلاث طائرات حربيه تابعه لها لاطلاق نار
ارغ على العوده والغاء عمليه اجلاء
الاربعاء الماضي قبل ان تحط طائره عسكريه
في الخرطوم لاحقا للبدء باجلاء الرعايه
تركيا اعلنت انها ستنظم عمليات اجلاء
مواطنيها عبر بلد ثالث واجلت احدى هذه
العمليات بعد انفجارات قرب نقطه تجمع
حددتها السفاره التركيه واذا كانت دول قد
دخلت مرحله تنفيذ عمليه الاجلاء فهناك دول
ما زالت في مرحله الاعداد ومنها ايطاليا
التي ارسلت طائرات الى جيبوتي وكذا هولندا
التي ارسلت طائرتين الى الاردن استعدادا
لاجلاء 152 هولنديا اما اليونان فقد ارسلت
طائره عسكريه وعددا من جنود القوات الخاصه
الى مصر لاجلاء 120 يونانيا من السودان
ونفذت السعوديه اول عمليه اجلاء ناجحه
انطلاقا من بورتسودان وصولا الى جده في
رحله نقلت 157 شخصا منهم 91 سعوديا وسته
وستون شخصا من اثنتي عش ره جنسيه يبدو
الاجلاء عبر البر الافضل لاخراج اعداد
كبيره من الاجانب من السودان لكن المسافه
بين الخرطوم وبورسودان تبلغ 840 كيلومترا
وتامين هذا المسار الطويل في ظل ما يشهده
السودان من مواجهات يبدو امرا صعبا للغايه
من لندن ويليام
السفير البريطاني السابق لدى السودان سيد
فاتي دعني استفيد من خبرتك فيما يتعلق
بسابق معرفتك بهذا البلد بالسودان لتقيم
لي الوضع وما يجري كيف ترى هذا المشهد
المشهد السوداني الان
في الحقيقه ليس لدي اي معرفه ميدانيه ولكن
يبدو ان الجيش السوداني يتعاون مع القوات
الدوليه ويسمح للقوات الدوليه
بتخط طائرات لاجلاء رعاياها تمكن
البريطانيون من ارسال طائرتين في الخرطوم
بحري من اجل اجلاء الرعايه بالاضافه الى
الفرنسيين
والامريكيين وبالتالي يبدو ان الجيش
السوداني يتعاونوا مع الدول الاجنبيه من
اجل تمكين هذه الدول من اجلاء السفارات
وموظفي السفارات ولكن الوضع الميداني لا
يزال صعبا للغايه ولم يتم التوصل الى وقفا
لاطلاق النار يسمح لاجلاء الرعايه
البريطانيه
هذه الدول التي استطاعت ان تجلي رعاياها
وبعثاتها الدبلوماسيه من السودان الم تكن
تستطيع ان تمارس ذات الضغط الضغط وذات
الدور على الاقل لتثبيته الهدى السابقه
في الحقيقه اعتقد ان هذه الدول تعمل بكد
وجده على المستوى الدبلوماسي بالتنسيق مع
الحلفاء والاصدقاء من مثل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات العربيه المتحده ومصر
ودول اخرى في المنطقه في محاوله منها
للتوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار بالتعاون مع
الاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده والهيئه
الحكوميه للتنميه ايجاد كل هذه الاطراف
تحاول ان تستخدم السبل الدبلوماسيه من اجل
ارغام او من اجل اقناع الطرفين لكي يتوقف
عن القتال ولكن يبدو ان ايا منهما لا يود
ان يتخلى عن موقفه الان هناك مخاوف جديه
سفير باتي بان بخروج البعثات الدبلوماسيه
الاجنبيه معنى ذلك ان الوضع خاصه الانسان
وما يتعلق بالمدني سيكون
خاصه في العاصمه الخرطوم
اعتقد ان الوضع الانساني هو في وضع سيء
اصلا لان البعثات الانسانيه تعرضت
للهجوم عدد من العاملين في الامم المتحده
تم الاعتداء عليهم
وقتلوا
وعاملون في مجال الاغاثه الانسانيه تعرضوا
لهجمات عندما كانوا في القوافل وبالتالي
حتى يتمكن هؤلاء من الحصول على ضمانات
امنيه حول سلامه متطوعين والموظفين يصعب
ان تعمل هذه المنظمات في الميدان وبالتالي
الضغط بالنسبه على الجيش وبالنسبه الى
الضغط على الطرف الاخر قوات الدعم السريع
هذا ما يتعين علينا ان ننتظر لنرى بعد
اجلاء الدبلوماسي
السفير البريطاني السابق لدى السودان شكرا
جزيلا لك الحدث الابرز هذا اليوم هو
التمكن من اجلاء الكثير من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه من مختلف المنافذ سواء برا او
بحرا وكذلك
جوا سواء او حتى من طاقه من داخل مطار
الخرطوبه وتطور مهم فيما يتعلق باجلاء هذه
البعثات والسؤال الكبير في السودان ماذا
بعد اجلاء هذه البعثات على الصعيد الامني
والانساني والمدني خاصه في العاصمه
الخرطوم من السفيره سوزان بيج نائبه بيج
نائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
السابق للشؤون الافريقيه والمستشاره
السابقه للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى
السودان اهلا بك السفيره بيج وابدا ايضا
معك من خلال خبرتك في السودان مضى اسبوع
الان هل بدا يتشكل لدى المجتمع الدولي و
واشنطن تصور لمالات الامور في السودان
شكرا جزيلا على هذه الاستضافه الكريمه اود
ان اقول انني اعتقد وكما اشار حضره السفير
البيطاني السابق ويليام بيتي انه من الصعب
ان نتحدث عن عمليه التاثير مع اجلاء
الدبلوماسيين والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
الاجنبيه من البلاد اذا تصعب هذه العمليه
التوصل الى فرض لوقف لاطلاق النار من اجل
حل المسائل العالقه والتوصلي الى اتفاق
نهائي ولكن اعتقد ان واشنطن على درايه
بالديناميات الميدانيه التي تجري حاليا في
السودان هل تعتقدين بان المجتمع الدولي
خاصه الدول الكبرى وعلى راسها
واشنطن فعلت كلما تستطيع على الاقل على
الصعيد الانساني لتثبيت هدنه في السودان
لاجلاء المدنيين
في الحقيقه
وبالنسبه الى ما ذكر في السابق وذكرنا هذه
النقطه من قبل من الصعوبه بمكان ان نرغم
الناس على تصرف بطريقه اذا ما لم يكونوا
هؤلاء لديهم الرغبه ان الدول عملت على
اجلاء الرعايه والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
بالنظر الى الظروف الميدانيه وبعد استمرار
القتال لايام طويله وبالتالي تعين على هذه
الدول ان تتواصل مع القوات المسؤوله عن
المطارات للتنسيق من اجل اجلاء
الدبلوماسيين اعتقد ان هذه الدول بدلت
قصار جهدها لاجلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه
النقطه الاساسيه هي ان
القتال قد يزيد سوءا بعد خروج هذه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه من البلاد اصوات في داخل
السودان عن طريق وسائل الت واصل الاجتماعي
تقول
العالم خرج البعثات الدبلوماسيه خرجت من
الخرطوم وتركتنا لوضعنا ولحالنا نواجه
لوحدنا الرصاص
الحقيقه اعتقد ان هذه النقطه تعبر بالفعل
عن احباط الشعب السوداني وخصوصا
السودانيون الذين شاركوا بالثوره السلميه
التي ادت الى الاطاحه بنظام عمر البشير
هذه الثوره التي ادت الى املا ولكن بعد
ذلك جرى الانقلاب بقياده من الجنرال برهان
والجنرال الحماتي ولكن انا اعرف ان الناس
لا يزالون يحاولون ان يبذلوا قصار جهد
خصوصا على المستوى الانساني ان السودانيين
وخصوصا من خلال لجان المقاومه عملت بشكل
دؤوب لمساعده الناس وتامين الماكل والمشرب
والامدادات الطبيه وكل المساعدات الاغاثيه
وحتى حاولت ان تساعد الناس كي يخرج من
مناطق النزاع وبالتالي هناك جهود مبذوله
ونامل ان الاسره الدوليه حتى مع اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه سوف تتمكن من الضغط
باتجاه الهدوء والتاكد من ان السودانيين
سوف يكونون جزءا من اي حل في المستقبل من
نائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق للشؤون الافريقيه والمستشاره
السابقه للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك
تثير الوتيره المتسارعه لاجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من السودان
تساؤلات حول دلالات تلك العمليات وما اذا
كانت تشير الى ان الاوضاع هناك غير مستقره
ومرشحه لمزيد من التصعيد كما يتساءل
سودانيون عن قدره المجتمع الدولي على
التاثير في مجريات الاحداث في بلدهم لا
سيما وان قوه غربيه منخرطه منذ اعوام في
مسيره انتقاله الديمقراطي المفترضه
قد تشتد وقد تطول هي ذي مواجهات السودان
المسلحه في قراءه متشائمه اصحابها يجدون
في تكثيف جهود اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من البلد ما يدعم
رؤيتهم لا يستوقفهم في المشهد حق الدول
تقديم سلامه مواطنيها على اي اعتبار اخر
حيثما تفجرت اضطرابات من اي نوع وانما يشد
انتباههم ما يعتبرون انه اداره المجتمع
الدولي ظهره للسودان في محنته الاحداث
لم يغب ذاك المجتمع عن محاولات السودان ما
بعد الثوره على حكم البشير الخروج من وضع
المازوم اقتصاديا ومحاصر دبلوماسيا وكانت
لافته مرافقته للبلد في محاولته الانتقال
الى الحاله الديمقراطيه التي نشدتها ثورته
للامم المتحده بعثه خاصه لدعم ذلك
الانتقال وتمت الى جانبها اليه ثلاثيه
الحقت بعدها برباعيه
بالرغم من تلاحق المؤشرات لم يحطط احد
بنزع فتيل الازمه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
قبل ان تنزلق الى الاقتتال والان يشكو
كثيرون ما بدا لهم غياب الضغوط المجديه
على طرفي الصراع والعجز عن التاثير
الايجابي على مجريات الاحداث فحتى الهدن
الانسانيه لا ترى كما يبدو من زاويه كونها
فرصه لتوقيع وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
فالتركيز والزخم الاساسي ظل منصبين بحسب
بعض المتابعين على هدى تتيح اجاء الرعايه
الاجانب وليس على اعمال الاغاثه الانسانيه
او دبلوماسيه السلام
ليست دبلوماسيه حرب خالصه تجادل عواصم
غربيه
لقد اتخذنا قرارا باغلاق السفاره
البريطانيه مؤقتا في الخرطوم واجلاء
الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلاتهم ونقل
وظائفنا الدبلوماسيه الى موقع دبلوماسي
قريب نواصل العمل بشكل مباشر ومن خلال
شركائنا الدوليين للدعوه الى وقف اطلاق
النار ووضع حد لهذا العنف
هل تمت اذا قراءه المختلفه لاغلاق
السفارات واجراء الرعايه والدبلوماسيين
الاجانب من السودان ربما فبموازاه تلك
الاجراءات ينشط حديث الوساطات لا سيما
منها الاقليميه من اجل وقف الاقتتال
وانهاء معاناه المدنيين داخل السودان
يتحدث الاتحاد الاوروبي عن اتصالات جاريه
مع كل من البرهان وحميدتي لحذفهما على
انهاء الاقتتال
اما المبعوث النرويجي الخاص للسودان فيؤكد
للجزيره العمل مع قوى اقليميه للتوصل الى
وقف لاطلاق النار
للغايه ذاتها تنسق الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وهما من ابرز القوه الغربيه
المنخرطه في مسيره الانتقال الديمقراطي
المهدده الان في السودان وفي السودان لا
يبدو للناس هناك منصفا المطالبه بممرات
امنه لاجلاء مواطنين اجانب دون الالحاح في
المطالبه بوقف القتال حتى لو الحوا في
الطلب فتمت مشكله
كل اللاعبين الدوليين في السودان لن يبقى
نفسه حتما بعد اكتمال خروج مواطنيهم
ودبلوماسييهم من هناك
في استراليا السيد جوناس هورنر مسؤول ملف
السودان السابق في مجموعه الازمات الدوليه
اهلا بك سيد جوناس مثل ما ورد في التقرير
الان سيدنا هل باعتقادك ان المجتمع الدولي
فعل خاصه الدول ذات الثقل فعلت كلما
تستطيع من اجل وقف اطلاق النار ولو بشكل
مؤقت
في الحقيقه كلا لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ان كان
هناك نقصا في الفعل في هذا المجال
وبالتالي لم يتم استخدام
الاوراق الاساسيه
ونتحدث هنا لربما عن ضغوطا ماليه كان
بالامكان ان تستخدم على الطرفين
المتقاتلين وهنا يمكننا ان نشير الى هذه
الادوات التي يمكن ان تؤثر وبالتالي لدينا
ايضا موقف الاطراف في المنطقه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ومصر ربما بالاضافه الى
اطراف اخرى في المنطقه يمكن ان تؤدي دورا
في هذا المجال وبالتالي الرساله الاساسيه
بالنسبه الى الدول الغربيه هي ان تتواصل
مع الدول الاقليميه لمحاوله التاثير على
الوضع الميداني وبالتالي دراسه
اوراق التي يمكن ان تستخدم خصوصا على
مستوى الماليه هل من تفسير لماذا لا تقوم
بهذا الدور
في الحقيقه اعتقد ان الدول الغربيه فهمت
انه في السودان هناك محدوديه كبيره
بالنسبه الى اوراق الضغط التي لديها من
جهه وعلى مر السنوات الاربعه ونصف الماضيه
بعد الثوره في السودان كان هناك ضغط من
قبل واشنطن وايضا من قبل لندن وحكومات
غربيه اخرى للانتقال باتجاه الحكم
الديمقراطي المدني في السودان ولكن الطريق
قد تشاطر السلطه في السودان لم تتغير
كثيرا عما كانت عليه ايام حكم عمر البشير
السابق وبالتالي هناك السيطره لقوه السلاح
وللقوات المسلحه في السودان وهو امرا لم
يتمكن السودان من التخلص منه وبالتالي في
السنوات الاربعه ونصف الماضيه بعد الثوره
وعمليه الانتقال التي كانت منتظره نحو
حكومه مدنيه
ديمقراطيه اعتقد ان هذه الدول لم تطبق او
تنفذ اوراق الضغط التي لكن كامل بسبب
واعذرني على المقاطعه هذه الدول نجحت في
اجلاء رعاياها بشكل او باخر واكيد ان
الضغط واحد من ادوات التي ادت الى نجاح
هذا الاجلاء لما لم تستعمل هذا الضغط من
اجل تثبيت الهدنه
اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن مستويين مختلفين بشكل
كبير من الضغط في هذا المجال هناك ضغط من
نوع اخر يمكن ان يستخدم لاجلاء
الببلوماسيه وهنا الدور ايضا
ينصب على المتقاتلين الجهتين المتقاتلتين
وانا يمكنني ان ارى لماذا اود كل من هاتين
الجهتين ان تتعاونا التعاون مع البعثات
الدوليه في عمليه الاجلاء ان هذه الجهات
المتقاتله لم تكن تابه بحياه المدنيين
وكان هناك نهب ايضا حتى للمساعدات
الانسانيه وارتكابات اخرى جرت في البلدان
في السودان
شكرا لك واعتذر منك فقد ادركنا الوقت من
ميلبرز في استراليا جولس هونر مسؤول ملف
السودان السابق في مجموعه الازمات الدوليه
شكرا
قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه انه تم الابلاغ
عن مقتل 420 شخصا واصابه
30800 ممن منذ تصاعد العنف في السودان
منتصف الشهر الجاري واضافت المنظمه في
بيان انه كان من الممكن انقاذ ربع الضحايا
الذين فوق فقدوا ارواحهم لو تمكن العاملون
في مجال الرعايه الصحيه من الوصول الى
المدنيين المصابين كما اعلنت منظمه الصحه
العالميه انها غير قادره في الوقت الحالي
على نشر المزيد من مجموعات الجراحه
الاساسيه في ظل تعطل المطارات والطرق غير
الامنه وقالت المنظمه انها على اهبه
الاستعداد لاستغلال اول فرصه للمساعده دون
المساس بسلامه موظفينا في بيئه خطره بشكل
متزايد على العاملين في المجال الانسانيه
معنى من لندن مارتن بلوت الخبير في الشان
الافريقي بمعهد دراسات
الكومنويلز سيد مارتن كيف تقيم تطور
الاحداث مره الان اسبوع على المواجهات في
الاشتباك كيف تطور الاحداث وهذه المقاربه
الدوليه حتى الان في التعامل مع هذا الوضع
الامني الخطير في السودان
في الحقيقه ان الوضع في السودان
كارثي هذا ما يمكننا ان نراه هو من
الصعوبه بمكان ان نرى كيف لسكان الخرطوم
وايضا سكان المدن السودانيه المختلفه كيف
لهم ان يستمروا هناك قتال كبير في دارفور
وفي مناطق سودانيه مختلفه الوضع كارثي ومن
المؤسف انه تطلب الامر حتى الان لكي تنخرط
الاسره الدوليه وتفهم حجم الازمه وحجم ما
يتعرض له الشعب السوداني وبدات الاسره
الدوليه برد الفعل الامر صعب للغايه
بالنسبه الى الاتحاد الافريقي حتى لم
يتمكن الاتحاد الافريقي من ارسال بعث الى
مطار الخرطوم حيث كان القتال يدور بين
جنرال حميتي وال جنرال برهان هذه نقطه
مهمه في البدايه المجتمع الدولي اوكل هذه
المهمه للاتحاد الافريقي ثم حدث الذي ذكرت
الان هل معنى ذلك انه تم تجاوز هذا الدوره
بالتالي يجب ايجاد صيغ دوليه اكثر فاعليه
في الحقيقه بكل صراحه اعتقد ان هذا الامر
لن يحل
بالقريب العاجل طبعا
بكل اسف اعبر عن هذه الفكره لاننا نتحدث
عن طرفين يتواجهان ويحاولان ان يعززاه
المكاسب ويرسخها
السلطه والسيطره كلاهما مقتنع بان
باستطاعته ان يحسم المعركه عسكريا وحتى
يقتنع اي منهما بعكس ذلك من الصعوبه بمكان
بالنسبه الى المجتمع الدولي ان يتدخل
ويؤثر وبالتالي اذا ما كانت النيه
للاستمرار بالقتال سوف يستمر القتال
البلاد كبيره من حيث المساحه وهناك تنوع
كبير لربما هناك امكانيه ارسال قوه صغيره
لمحاوله اجنااء الاكثر ضعفا والاكثر هشاشه
ولكن هذا حتى هذا الامر سوف يكون في غايه
الصعوب لذا لما ذكرت الان بخروج البعثات
الدبلوماسيه الاجنبيه تتوقع ان يتفاقم
الوضع اكثر باجازه وتكرمت
نعم انا اعتقد ان الامر سوف يصبح اكثر
سوءا بكثير لان الضغط لم يعد موجودا من
الداخل
والاسره الدوليه لديها المئات والالاف من
الرعايه في السودان ويجب اجلاء هؤلاء ولكن
عندما نتحدث عن هذا الامر ماذا بالنسبه
الى الملايين من السودانيين في الخرطوم
الذين ليس باستطاعتهم ان يخرجوا البعض
منهم يمكن ان يخرج الى الجاره واعتذر منك
من لندن مارتن الخبير في الشهاده الافريقي
تزداد اعداد القتلى والجرحى يوميا بسبب
الحرب المستعره في الخرطوم وتسقط اعداد
كبيره من المدنيين بسبب الرصاص الطائش في
مناطق كانت بعيده نسبيا عن اماكن الاشتباك
تقرير احمد فهال ولد الدين
يعدد الرصاصه الطائش الذي اخترق بيته في
هدئه ليلي ام درمان فالصراعات العسكريه في
شوارع الخرطوم قتلت ابن اخيه النائمه في
سريره
المرحوم ده اخونا ده مات فيه سريره
بس سريره
وبعد السرير ضربه وواحد العوضه
يعني
[موسيقى]
الخرطوم المحصورون وراء جدرانهم فيرون
مواكب الاجلاء تتوالى سفاره
تجلي رعاياها
كما يرون اساسيات العيش الطبيعي تتلاشى
قطره قطره
فالماء اصبح رفاهيه في عاصمه ارض النيلين
يحاول السودانيون على عادتهم التكاثف
ومشاركه اللقمه حسب المستطاع بواسطه
مبادرات عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لكن
تحديات توفر الكهرباء والانترنت تحد من كل
ذلك حصلت
زي الصدمه للناس فما كان عارفين يعملوا
شنو
كان في عدد من الحوجات بيتم مشاركتها عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وفي ناس ثانيين بيكون عندهم حاجات متوفره
برضو بيعلنوا عنها انها متوفر عندهم كذا
لا توجد ارقام دقيقه عن الاثار الانسانيه
للحرب المتكشفه مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
الشؤون اللاجئين تحدث عن نزوح كبير من
الخرطوم بحثا عن اماكن اكثر امنا وطمانينه
فمع كل يوم حرب جديد يرتفع عدد القتلى
والجرحى كما ترتفع نسب الخارجين من
الخرطوم حرصا على طمانينه سرقتها اعيرت
النيران